tuesday airbnb announced that it plans
to sell 2.8 billion dollars worth of its
stock
at 44 to 50 per share during their
upcoming initial public offering
this would put the home retail company's
value anywhere from 30.6 billion dollars
to thirty four point eight billion
dollars
airbnb's three billionaire founders
brian chesky
joe gebbia and nathan blatrick will each
sell less than one percent of their
current stakes at the offering
about 630 000 shares apiece
worth roughly 28 million dollars at the
low end of the pricing range
that will leave chesky the ceo with
around 11
of the company after the offering a
stake worth at least
point four billion dollars at the low
end of the ipo pricing
blsic the chief strategy officer and
gebia the chief
product officer will each own just under
stakes worth at least 3.1 billion
dollars
each airbnb has not been immune to the
effects of the coronavirus pandemic
the company's private valuation dropped
from 31 billion dollars to 18 billion
dollars this year
following a huge drop in business as
travel halted due to the pandemic
in the first nine months of 2020 the
company posted 2.5 billion dollars in
revenues
a 48 drop from last year but
the company and investors seem to be
betting on the company making a rebound
when coveted restrictions ease
and people resume traveling the company
reported net income of 219 million
dollars in the third quarter
up from a net loss of 575.6 million
dollars in the second quarter showing
some signs of a rebound given how tech
ipos have performed so far in 2020
it would not be surprising if the shares
exceeded the targeted ipo price on
opening day
you